I just haven't talked about it because I
don't want to put him on blast but but
there's a point of like
come on dude I don't know what he's
gonna do
[Music]
perfect what's up guys my name is Thomas
dopizziola whatever you want to call me
welcome back to the dope as usual
podcast we're here to talk about live
drugs problems accomplishments and
everything in between I am here with my
co-host Marty O'Neill what's up guys
what's up guys welcome to season three
I'm trying not to yell first episode of
season three as you can see behind Marty
behind me it's not just our warehouse
anymore we have officially moved you
guys know we've been talking about it
for a long time we're here with
malcolmedia thank you guys very much
appreciate you guys uh it's not just
Marty going
camera on is the camera on
thank you guys for being here this you
guys don't want to understand how stoked
we are right now yes so guys behind the
cameras we're just the shot just Marty
and I anymore so thank you guys so much
for being here season three episode one
we said in episode like seven hopefully
by like season three or something we're
signing a deal like how people help us
um
and this episode is coming out timing
almost two years to the day to the day
yes February 8th we posted our very
first video
what's today the Third
oh it come out with the sixth let's turn
my Ritter on there
so that's speaking into existence guys
oh yeah all right almost like 750 days
later to the day here we go guys we're
gonna get right into it we're still on
nice guy clock I am not going to start
smoking yet uh but we are going to bless
this damn uh set because we haven't
smoked a smidge of wheat here yet but
let's get straight into this guys I'm
excited I'm gonna start this off with
something that we haven't done and um
it's so everybody does who would you
rather what would you rather do but this
is for Marty so Marty are you ready for
the first thing we're gonna talk about
in season three and this is a solo
episode guys solo episodes as we know is
like the teachers out of the room we can
just talk [__] so here we go there's no
guests it's just Marty and I Marty are
you ready yeah you know it are you ready
are you sure you ready for this question
would you rather all right all right
would you rather do marathon training
with David Goggins
okay or spar with Mike Tyson oh God
that's not even uh wait which one
question I'd rather be thrown into the
ocean than spiral with Tyson oh okay I
thought you were gonna say yeah the
other way around
my pants
shins with David Goggins before I get in
the chest yeah yeah no I mean because if
I started training with David Goggins at
some point like if we're running next to
each other at some point I'm just gonna
like you're a beast die no oh I'm just
gonna stop running and of course you're
like if I'm training I'm a beast too
good I thought you meant something else
there's gonna be distance created
somewhere early on between me and him
I'm gonna be interviewing on the whole
education will happen very soon in that
run yes you guys can be on very opposite
sides there yeah nowhere there's no
winds with sparring with tires and I'm
not gonna I gotta be honest though you
be a beast after running with David
goggles for a while but getting hit by
that man that many times you're not
gonna get better yeah you're just gonna
be more afraid yeah I would be you're
going in the rudder for that I could
barely hang with Cam I'd rather be with
your eight-year-old son yeah you're
saying he hits you that hard we go
pretty hard you can't take it is it that
bad no I'm saying he oh he's going Full
Steam and I'm eating shots
yeah checking kicks you don't see these
footage he's throwing spinning back I've
watched it but yes but you checking his
kicks yeah
I'm so happy he's nice bro yeah I know
because you ever see those movies where
like the dad fights the sun like that's
coming it's like a bad kid and Karate
Kid yeah but uh he cares not a jerk so
if he was a jerk could you imagine yeah
could you like that Kevin Hart's game
like take out the trash except it's like
I'm gonna beat your ass dad
um could you imagine being Arnold's dad
but also how did we get on to this this
that was a far left this is the David
Goggins yeah okay David Goggins David
Goggins yeah um so you're picking David
Goggins training all right yeah one of
the things he teaches you is that you
got to run out of pace that you can talk
so I'm taking that all day so I'm gonna
just be well I'll hang in there for a
few miles I'll be watching a joint if
you can inhale and not just be coughing
that's a good Pace if I could smoke weed
and jog I would totally that sounds like
a vlog oh dude I do I do the treadmill
and I take bong ribs and you know you've
seen it yeah yeah it's the best thing
you've ever done in your life imagine
forgetting that you're running like oh
yeah
[__] iron it's fun yeah I just watch
YouTube on my little platform and then
that's it running with and without a
bong rip is two different [__] things
completely
yeah but a dirty bone rip will make that
workout just trash sorry I know we're
talking about things that we probably
don't do but you should try them have
you ever smoked a joint in your shower I
have many times I haven't done in the
new house yet smoke will joined the
shower bong in the shower smoking weed
and then going under the water in a pool
and letting it out is [__] awesome
too it does nothing but it's like
it's different
okay that's it that's it sorry my bad
David Goggins um me too I'd rather [__]
and pass out and wake up not beat up
because like it seems like it wouldn't
be a good comparison but what he means
by training with Dave and goggin says
you gotta you're gonna end up pissing
black you're [__] yourself he runs
200 you're having broken knees
afterwards my foot hurts now yeah from
standing at meet and greets my Arch
broke
yeah I don't know if I told you yet my
Arch broke from the Miami meet and greet
crumble
okay you ever see those Mexican toys
that you press this you don't talk about
those Mexican toys you press the string
at the bottom they just collapse yeah
that's me yeah and you're standing back
up
all right guys Super Bowl's finally here
this Sunday the biggest event in sports
it's officially here guys DraftKings
sports book the official betting partner
of Super Bowl 57. this Super Bowl is
going to be awesome guys for all the
betting people out there you know
DraftKings is the place to go new
customers go to DraftKings Sportsbook
bet five dollars and get 200 and free
bets instantly five dollars get you 200
instantly all customers can get on on
the Super Bowl 57 excitement with
DraftKings happy hour super boosts so go
ahead and check out the DraftKings
Sportsbook app every single day between
six and nine eastern Time or three and
six Pacific Standard Time those times
you can check the app and you'll see
which prop bet is boosted and I am
notoriously wrong on this show for
picking the Super Bowl winner I have not
picked the winner two seasons in a row
I'm gonna go for the Eagles
I don't know man Mahomes is going to win
eight more Super Bowls in his career
let's see what the Eagles got so right
now go download the draftking Sportsbook
app and remember use our code Yola all
new customers bet five dollars get 200
instantly in free bets minimum age and
eligibility restrictions apply void in
Ohio see show notes for details remember
just download DraftKings Sportsbook app
and use code Yola
we have to bless the spot are you ready
for your joints thank you for the Tyson
ashtray
what a way to start yes
yes
so we have to start the season off in a
good way yeah and to start the season
off right these are little cigars
so these are about nine eight grams I
think ish seven not seven quarters
that's why and we need our own
individual lighters here so let's spark
it up thank you guys for being here
thank you guys me wow yeah
um we're sparking it up guys I I
appreciate I'm gonna put this closer
party uh I'm not lengthy like that
all right guys here we go we're gonna
spark this up for everyone driving
please be safe yes that's you have to do
it for everyone's driving please be safe
um we haven't said that but season one I
mean we've been saying season one be
careful I know a lot of people crash
laughing we've had it
six different accidents in the DMS of
was like I was listening and laughing
and I wrecked I re-rented somebody
please be careful this season is going
to be a lot of things you're going to
want to look at just keep your eyes on
the road all right just just keep watch
just keep listening and come and hang
out with us later but if you're in the
car there's a gigantic gorilla finger in
Marty's hand and eyes so here we go
all right especially goes for all Super
Bowl related alcohol events what oh
you're saying be careful yeah Uber who
was 14 dollars
prison is a long time and a DUI is 10K
all right just do the do the Uber charge
have your friend pay for it if you're
broke it's totally cool or walk shoelace
Express guys it's cheaper than going to
jail
here we go
so which would you pick
David Goggins okay I'm gonna [__] my
pants break my legs already said it okay
no way no way all right next next topic
this is a good weight huh oh yeah it's
so much this might be the biggest one
I've ever participated in no the 100
gram joint okay yeah
you hit it yeah yeah all right there we
go all right so uh we're starting the
season off with what's good guys the
segment we like to call what's good and
we we don't really talk about negative
things unless it was happening to us
because then it's funny but let's say
what's good and good things that go on
Earth just positive things things you
don't see in the news because the news
always talk about some [__] so
what's good the first thing we're going
to talk about is something I saw and
definitely this guy's the [__] you know
he smokes bowls and you know he's super
nice this guy I don't know if you saw
the video
he put it on Tick Tock I believe so this
is what's going on he on take time goes
hey I just got my bag from McDonald's
and he opens it up like I only ordered a
chicken sandwich he opens it up and it's
their drop to the bank for the day
they put it in the bag and gave him the
drop of the McDonald's the bank the
whole Vault to go drop at the bank and
they gave it to a guy and a customer and
he goes and films himself returning it
right he's like oh hell I'm not going to
take this money which is dope as hell
which is super sick how old was he
like 23-ish
okay yeah and he gave it he gave it back
okay so in this situation what a badass
he's got good parents yeah you want to
give mate 23. oh you would have snatched
that never used to ghetto as hell that's
okay it's okay Marty it's okay Mark are
you still in the rap on the come up it's
okay
it's okay at 23. he said no I don't want
to add 7K no so I would have thought
that was just God like no the the bail
the bindle coming from the plane of
money is God okay that's God that's or
drug dealers but that's good that that's
somebody losing their job uh that's the
cop showing up at your door asking for
that [__] afterwards yeah get it still
you didn't steal it yeah I don't know
all I know is what a badass and they
gave him free McDonald's which is like
hey here's 12 which is cool but for life
I don't know is it for the month I was
like you know what that's cool they did
something for you because most people
don't give a [__] I the reason I brought
this up because it brings me to a story
uh I stayed at uh at a hotel all right
with my grandma Dolores and my grandpa
Tom one of the first times I stayed at a
hotel
it's an adventure when you're six years
old the whack-ass waffles and [__]
still [__] like yo there's a
breakfast free what the [__] yeah you
eat all those grapes that was me so
we're at the pool with my grandma and
I'm doing the whole open eye chlorine
[__] because it's the 90s you know I'll
give a [__] my eyes are [__]
bloodshot red and they hurt and I'm
doing the whole rubbing thing where all
the skin hurts you know I'm doing that
and I'm going through and I look at the
bottom of the pool and as a kid what do
you do oh I can touch the bottom drain
and [__] come back up can you that's
what it was cool when you were a kid
right so I go to the bottom I'm like
that's a lot of leaves and I touch it
and it's like four hundred dollars
twenties fives hundreds of somebody just
got in the pool with it in their hot
pocket I grabbed it like this and I came
up I shot I was a child I was innocent I
didn't know I should but I was like who
dropped this money I just started saying
it as I got out of the pool
and as soon as I got out of the pool
there was a guy already doing this in
his pockets looking around my oh it's
his and he looks at me and I go
he goes thank you he probably played me
probably wasn't his but I remember
giving it to him and he's like
your parents man I was like good kid oh
yeah it's not mine
no why would I keep it it's not mine and
he goes you know what here here's a 20
go no don't worry I got 16 upstairs
that's what I was collecting change and
I knew exactly to the dollar Cent I had
like oh I found 12 coins today I'm up 17
bucks whatever I told him like don't
worry man I got 17 upstairs keep that
money you know what I mean I was like
[__] I thought it was a baller it was
five or six yeah and but yeah I would
return the money to McDonald's that's
what that's what I was getting it all
right but um I probably could have got
jump if I was in Merced we were down
here in La that's a nice spot with my
grandma
but that's it Marty what's good I think
I returned the money I thought it was
too much worth of rent right there 23.
yeah
I couldn't I commend him man he must
have a [__] I don't think I could do it
I just always feel like the person that
dropped it is panic in panic mode I
remember my mom lost her whole paycheck
outside of the bank once
and it was devastating when we were kids
that type of [__] will put you in a
panic like uh I had Bank America be like
hey guess what we closed your account
we're mailing you all your money he'll
get in like three weeks one time that
type of [__] yeah I actually left a 10
pack of weed at my friends at a party
I went and sold them one pound brought
it all in left it drove 20 minutes away
[__] pulled over went in the trunk
Dove and that [__] called him and
nobody touched it nobody it was a party
it's not like a kickback it was a party
and I went back and he just came out the
door like this and I was like I love you
Jeremy
you could just save me 25 000 sir God
damn thank you so much man because it
wasn't all mine so I would have been
[__] but yeah that's a that's some
good [__] on people man I like have you
seen those Tick Tock videos of
[__] returning wallets
tag me and [__] like that stop tagging
me in super fat dudes dancing that look
like me on Tick Tock I get that [__] 600
times a day like what's up why are you
dancing like is this Yola bro that
fool's in a bed he's bedridden come on
man
I get little ass kids that look like you
oh all day the kid that like 10 year old
that's driving yeah in Oakland yeah I
told you I used to drive when I was a
child
that shit's crazy you would never get
away with it now
too many cell phones but for sure for
damn sure let me get somebody swallowed
her I got another little what's good to
interject Charlie [__] rocket
making it happen with Livy's dream
clothing line he wasn't just talking the
talk at Ted Talk they brought it into
reality they really did it it's a real
thing he saw it all the way through he's
got huge celebrities rocking the line
she had her dreams see that yeah her
dreams
come true somebody tried to hate on them
and copyright their logo what yeah they
had to rework the logo they got past it
they made it happen so shout out to
copyright a little girl's logo
or say that it was too close to their
logo it was a cloud with a smiley bro
but that's the worst publicity you could
possibly oh if someone called their
clothing line Yelp is Dola and it was
for a little girl I'm not gonna copy
seriously go ahead you know what maybe
if your parents are pieces of [__] hold
on let me take that back don't even just
let myself out there
[Music]
conditionally yeah we'll see but no [__]
that's awesome yeah that's crazy that
somebody did that though uh Charlie
rocket go watch that video
um came out three weeks ago I think one
of the last episodes of season two that
feels dope as hell dope as hell and for
everyone that keeps asking Ted Talk will
come out whenever they put it out
because they get to pick which TED Talks
they want on their Channel me and Marty
we're not explicit in our Ted sock but
we're mad passionate in that Ted Talk
might have been talking about some [__]
so much so YouTube limited the audio
version of it for instance instantly
limited our audio anyway uh if Ted Talk
decides not to put it on their platform
we've logged the whole thing we got it
all recorded we got the speech super
high depth into mics don't worry guys
it's been reviewed right now and they
gotta send it to Todd and then we'll see
we'll see guys all right we'll see
hopefully because I love this speech I'm
proud of the speech yes me too here we
go on to the next thing guys this is
what's good the last part of what's good
I watched this video today Marty I know
you don't watch YouTube like that you
know who Mr Beast I love those okay I'm
not a big I do YouTube as a profession
and I know about six YouTubers I don't
watch YouTube you guys know I watch
ignorant things on YouTube and fights
and Karen's getting
blasted
I watched the worst [__] I make a
playlist yeah oh no you don't want my
playlist it's just frustrating the whole
time or it's skaters retaliating against
people not letting them skate that's all
I watch on YouTube so I know Mr Beast is
one of the biggest YouTubers I've seen a
couple of his videos my little brother
loves that fool I saw this pop up on my
[__] and go what does this title say Mr
Beast cures a thousand people's
blindness you could pay for it you can
cure your blindness with money the
doctor in the video is like I'm gonna
butcher or whatever he said but it was
something to the effect of
90 of the world's blindness could be
carried with a 10-minute operation
something like that if people just had
the money to do it damn I'm gonna I'm
not gonna lie I was pressing 10 seconds
skip on the intro I just wanted to get
to the to the core of it so I didn't see
the doctor part I'm sorry yeah I skipped
around to two but I heard that part
that's sad but also
what a video what an idea go hey we got
money let's go do something positive
well I give out weed and [__] and you
know maybe people [__] but to fix
someone's eyesight what a gift I'm
talking to you to be blind are you yeah
you don't like parking
neither can my kids Cam just realized he
can't see yeah it's like completely out
of focus right now do you wear contacts
yeah oh that's right that's right you do
work yeah they don't work no they work I
can see now with the contacts but
without the content oh sorry I tried I
tried to go for a run without my I was
like I can go around without the
contacts
no I was like I hit the first little dip
on the sidewalk went down almost eight
[__] and I was like turn right around
pop the contact so sorry I couldn't even
imagine life with a blurry vision yeah
that sucks because you know I get up
early popping them things I'm serious
you can't see is your site that bad too
you wear glasses no oh [__] no so this
means a lot to me because I go get this
done let's go get this [__] done I'm
going to yeah I'm on it we're going to
get into all my medical [__] but uh it's
on the list that [__] is getting done
because oh that's cool it's no life
having contacts no I feel bad for myself
I never talked about this you know let
me show you right now
as a kid I couldn't hear at all I was
almost deaf as a kid I couldn't hear
[__] I told you this or no this is a
season one trick I think oh yeah so
season three we'll start it off for all
you new people out here so I couldn't
hear at all I used to have tubes in my
ears and uh it worked really well now I
can hear [__] from 8 bucks away
I don't know what happened but I can you
know I'll be like someone's here like
where like you can hear the engine from
two blocks away John's here oh dude I
don't know what it is like a [__] dog
now and uh
so they itched really bad they used to
itch because they they cut so that you
know as a kid I'm [__] seven I'm
doing this I'm in class I'm trying to
itch and then this happens
and I was like wait what just happened
and then I realized that I know I'm a
talent that no other child has I taught
my sister how to do it but look at this
I've been able to do that since I had
tubes in my ears I didn't look at your
oh yeah that's the face most people have
that's the face so your blindness in my
ears I know what it's like not to be
able to hear do you know what it's like
not to be able to use your legs yes sir
I sure do fears rain oh don't say that
that was [__] up
I was talking about Forrest Gump
Lieutenant Dan quo
phase right I talk we I talked to him
after but I was on Monsters I couldn't
even move I'm like you know what it's
like you have been so [__] up you
can't even move can't walk it's all dark
I just got out of a wheelchair
oh [__]
I'm interviewing this man I knew this
specifically you know my high ass use
your legs like an idiot I was talking
about Lieutenant Dan Forrest Gump right
now yes thank you for bringing up the
worst thing I ever said I pulled a Ryan
Seacrest
shake the blind guy's hand four times
that's what I did
like you never be able to use your legs
see that was a Forrest Gump reference
that seemed like a podcast reference
normally I catch them no it wasn't it
was Forrest Gump I forgot about the
phasering thing
damn I felt so dumb that day at least he
was funny about it [__] I
thought that was so [__] funny you
ready yes level here at a bunch of fools
blindness so shout out to Mr Beast even
even if you don't like YouTubers that's
badass I don't see no NFL player doing
that [__] so let's just put that out
there all right here we go under the oh
I'm gonna skip the LA the my next thing
I'll save it for a minute
you have a horror story with teeth yeah
oh cause we all know what happened to
mine what is yours yeah it's not as gory
as yours but I was that evil yours was
it's not as bad as it gets different if
you want to refresh maybe some of the
new listeners saw to my teeth and they
had to solve my teeth for Invisalign
this [__] didn't explain that to me
it's like no I talked about it going no
we [__] didn't you guys were talking
about the moon distracted I was talking
to resistant he was talking about lunar
[__] I'm like oh that's interesting
[__] you didn't tell me how to saw my
[__] teeth off
you left the car running in one end to
get I left the garage no no you need to
prep you go for [__] what because the
stall I go
and then she the guy started sawing my
teeth with a blade cutting my teeth to
be bigger and I had to cut them and then
halfway through as you guys know the
blade broke and he went in the back
because I don't have any more blades but
I can't not finish it
and he goes I have to do it by hand I go
are you [__] serious and he got a
little saw a little blade
I saw on my teeth down
like a lumberjack but they have to hit
the gum because it has to go into the
root this full einfelt could saw through
my [__] gums
that was so bad
I was more pissed than hurt you remember
that oh I sure do and my teeth had gats
in them for the first time in my life
for two weeks till they closed like a
forest I would have just grinded my
teeth I got Invisalign because my teeth
grind I will say if you grind your teeth
get invisalignment I don't grab my teeth
anymore I used to grind my teeth to a
powder in my sleep and now I'm all good
before drugs don't say it was from drugs
Grandma teeth I was a child I'm sorry
what's your Horror Story what the [__]
just happened to you what are you
talking about well it's been kind of
like a drawn out horror story because
I've never had any teeth issues I didn't
have braces I didn't have a retainer
I've always just been good I've never
had real dental work ever I got three of
my wisdom teeth taken out when I was 17.
okay that was something but they left
the one in me too I got this once I left
this with it so the one that they left
in and during season two
started to just knock out my other tooth
but all of her yeah and
I was like telling April like I think my
tooth's like getting knocked out we need
to get like some dental insurance I
think I need to go to the dentist
because when you're self-employed you
don't have insurance you have to go get
all your insurances
so I didn't have dental insurance so
she's like yeah sure thing I'll get
right on that so then
April oh my God yeah don't worry about
it I got you
little did I know this tooth is coming
down while I'm driving home from one of
the episodes right it just knocks out my
molar
so my wisdom tooth takes out like
tremors
the movie with Kevin Bacon you ever seen
Tremors no I'm gonna throw this out it's
an 80s movie it's got to be an 80s movie
it's coming bacon
87. you've never seen tremors
sorry continue my Bible we'll go later
so that was my first real tooth issue
and it just clean clean break knocked
out my back molars disgusting all right
I just lived with it it was fine which
was nature
so that I went into the dentist we
finally we get the dental insurance and
I go in there and they're like I've
never seen this happen before like a two
just the doctor was like shocked when he
looked at the X-ray like
the assistant was like I know did he say
were you a point guard are you shooting
a thousand I can tell by your teeth is
that what they said
you might have you should play D3
basketball
so
I had that issue with my teeth going on
but it was fine it worked itself out now
fast forward about two weeks later I'm
eating some peanuts
I think I got a peanut stuck in my tooth
eat the hardest thing on earth all I eat
is peanuts now that I've been working
out stop it yeah you're eating hard nuts
with [__] up teeth no this was at my
my tooth came out my teeth are fine
I mean some peanuts I think I have some
peanuts stuck in my tooth I work it out
with my tongue lo and behold it's half
my tooth over here on this side now
so now I got a broken tooth on this side
cracked from peanuts
so now back to this like
issue with you know going to the dentist
again so now I gotta go in yeah so I go
back to the dentist and now they're like
you gotta have a root canal
for your situation back here in your
mouth and a crown cool so they scheduled
it and it wasn't supposed to literally
be two days before the TED Talk
oh that's right that's right
oh that's what you had to do oh also try
to hold that [__] by the crutch
because if you squeeze it too much
you'll start there we go all right here
we go
so the dentist told me you're I'm like
are you sure I'm going to be able to do
this right before a TED Talk
and the one Dennis is like yeah you'll
be fine trust me you'll be good
so I go in there
and as I'm filling out the paperwork I
literally feel like I'm about to pass
out
because they're making me chat like each
thing they do you have to sign for we
will be drilling into your tooth we will
be carving out the insides of your tooth
all this [__] will be happening you have
to sign each thing off yeah and I was
just getting [__] woozy like reading
it yes
don't read it I had to sign off and
check that [__] that was all news to me
I didn't realize all that was going on
in a root canal yeah so then dig into
your head yeah I walked back in the room
and I saw the tray of [__] that they use
and I saw the girl's eyes she was all
ready to go and [__] and I literally
felt like I was about to pass out
probably the first time ever yeah she
was like you know ready to go yeah
I could feel that she was ready to go
and it [__] freaked me out and I
talked to the dude like I'm about to do
a TED Talk is this a good idea he's like
probably not
if you're not in pain you should
probably wait
so then we rescheduled it and I just
went back and did it this week
how do you feel now
I was still terrified but one main thing
in this kind of like a through line I
think for some of the things in today's
episode
if you get a cavity you don't treat that
cavity it starts eating away at your
tooth
they tell you you got to get a root
canal if you don't do it you can die
from that [__] and people don't realize
it poisoned your blood so many people
commented on my Instagram post about
like I had to get heart stints because I
didn't get it treated and almost killed
me
stuff like that that infection goes
directly to your heart and you die so
they nobody really ever explained that
to me no um real quick I won't say his
name because he's a piece of [__] but
this guy used to know we had a business
a long time ago [__] you been a business
a long time ago and uh his teeth were
[__]
[__] up
and we signed to deal with these people
and they put in the contract you have to
get your [__] teeth fixed before we
start business because we're not about
to have you have a [__] heart attack
after we invest this money because they
were like your teeth are rotting do you
know you can [__] die from that they
were so dead serious about him fixing
his [__] it wasn't like a damn Bluetooth
[__] that was more of like bro you're
gonna die from that so I understand that
that's real because I was like bro
that's [__] mean because Nara I went
to the doctor telling me it's serious
you could die from [__] up teeth and
not [__] up teeth I'm talking about
rotting ass teeth that shit's bad get it
taken out Pirates all right Pirates die
so yeah nothing aside from that it
wasn't that bad it really wasn't it was
kind of pain-free to be honest it was it
was weird to be it's weird you got to
sit there and have them do all this [__]
but you can't feel it were you awake yes
wide awake I'm just sitting there
looking at him they just pulled your
teeth were you awake no out oh when they
pulled my teeth at Western Dental yeah
that discount dental oh yeah I told you
they broke my [__] oh crunch they
crunched into pieces and scooped it yeah
because he couldn't pull it out because
he's gonna break my jaws like bro stop
pushing my [__] jaw you're gonna
break it and he's like do you want me to
leave I was like no I don't
[__] uh but I can hear my teeth
I can hear it crunching like Styrofoam
breaking well that was the next part so
you get the root canal and it's weird
because you're like so many people are
cringing right now you're in my tooth
you're inside my tooth right now
drilling it out like what they did to
Cam's bone in his arm is what they did
to my tooth oh hollowed it out filled it
up oh
but you can't feel it but it's just
shocking to know like damn there's just
this little bit of Novocaine between me
and this being complete torture right
now with us in this room
so they do that and then they got to put
a crown on it which is where they shave
down your entire tooth to the core and
then put a fake tooth on top of it
so that's where they were they literally
grinded it down like I don't know but
again not that bad don't let this [__]
scare you from not doing this [__]
because I could have did the Ted Talk
the next day I'm still scared I don't
want it it's scary but I mean it kind of
walked away from it like without a lot
of pain the rot I was Flex yeah if you
can do that do that I'll do that flexed
it out yeah
Marty what else did you have to do to
yourself this week this has been a
[__] I've been just trying to get my
[__] together for season three so that
there's no
emergencies because I like I was telling
you the other day historically that [__]
linger don't deal with it until it
becomes a [__] emergency yes
so what else did you have to do
so
a day after that I had to get ready to
have a [__] colonoscopy once
you once you're the age of uh the
Twilight Zone guys
you start getting checked 35. but not
usually see here's the conundrum my dad
died of colon cancer when he he got
diagnosed when he was like 40. so ever
since I've been 16 they've been telling
me you better get checked tomorrow you
better get checked tomorrow like but
insurance doesn't want to cover you to
get checked until you're you know like
whatever math it is still you're like 40
basically what the [__] they didn't want
to they don't want to pay to check you
till you're like 40 if you don't have
like symptoms yeah Dr Drew so
anyway this is another thing that's like
everybody needs to do because this [__]
will kill you and you can't be scared to
do it and it's just like so many people
commented when I posted on Instagram
about it
again you don't realize like everybody's
going through this [__] like
Corey the dude from tedx I had he's like
I had a golf ball sized polyp removed oh
I've already had to get a bunch of those
[__] scans
but I've always been scared because I've
never gotten checked and you're just
walking around like damn am I taking
time bomb do I don't know what's even
going on inside my own self like because
when my dad he went in for a colonoscopy
when he came back bam you got stage four
cancer you need a emergency treatment
you got to go in for surgery tomorrow
type [__] oh [__] yeah so it's like not
I mean yes you're dreading the procedure
you're also dreading the results yeah
you know what I mean because not
everything was different from that point
after this after this exam you know
built up in my mind so going into it
yeah yeah like I went to sleep woke up
first before I even opened my eyes he's
like there's no cancer and then I opened
my eyes I didn't even realize I was
asleep
the hardest part was putting IV and that
wasn't even hard they put the IV in
they're like you have to get an IV for
that yeah you go to sleep for that one
so this is like a day after I did the
goddamn root canal Crown now they're
putting me to sleep for this and the
prep for the colonoscopies no super fun
time either but once every five years
now you walk around knowing you don't
have that type of cancer or any other
[__] just gonna pop up and ruin your
life because that [__] that's scary my
stomach has been [__] up when we're
still going to the doctor I have to take
some damn you guys know from last season
my stomach was all [__] up and uh I'm
doing the allergy test to find out what
foods are hurting but I had to do the
damn colonic [__] where it flushes your
I did it the same [__] day you didn't
do [__] we'd even know I had to go get
this procedure
it's so I don't have to go get a cologne
it's basically they flush your
intestines and your colon out
and have fun thank you not fun not fun
but you have to do it myself something's
wrong I have to fix that [__] so
we're doing all this stuff right I call
it doing [__] you don't want to do do
[__] you don't want to do I definitely
don't want to do it yeah so not cool
next thing get the eyes fixed run this
Marathon me I'm gonna grow let me get
like six two yeah I'm filming I'm gonna
put on like so I think I'm gonna put on
a couple inches all right
I think if I stretch hard enough and
throw my back out enough if you're
hanging like a vampire long enough
like major or what if I just get all my
homies to pull my limbs a little yeah
and my limbs are just longer like
SpongeBob when he went on to prom
OTE you watch SpongeBob enough [__] you
guys know what I'm talking about
SpongeBob goes to prom that's how I'm
gonna look sick as hell
all right let's get on to this next what
is this get the [__] out what is that
new segment oh
all right oh it's called get the [__]
out of here okay go all right damn
demonetize that segment go for it no
we're deep in this one all right that's
what she said go away
first segment get the [__] out of here
Foods you didn't know weren't vegetarian
what
so these are foods that if you're just
if you're somebody that doesn't want to
eat meat in life you're going to be
shocked to find out that these have meat
in them what yes all right like average
foods are like boxed Foods
what happens we'll see yeah everything
yeah beef in it and this I'm burnt my
bad that was a dummy this is kind of
tied into the last thing we were talking
about too because after they said you
don't have cancer they're like just you
know be healthy and don't eat processed
food
that's the advice that they left me with
at the cancer hospital so going into
processed food here Foods you didn't
know weren't vegetarian go first of all
let's define what gelatin is gelatin is
sad are you guys ready why stopped
eating [__] candy for a long time
you know let's break it down my
stomach's been hurting
real bad for two years I haven't drank
soda I stopped drinking soda in 2015.
my uncle John died and I'm drinking a
damn Coke for this fool right now I'm
second I left my this fool be chugging
that [__] I was like that's fine I'm
gonna do one hooked I'm a do you know
how bad I'm addicted to soda
put it this way guys you know how much I
love weed
at my Peak [__] weed give me like 18
different sodas and I'm just gonna do I
won't even eat dopa soda the dope is
soda bro it was bad it was bad I would
drink soda not even eat food
I was like oh I kind of ate there's ice
in that [__]
it was bad dude I would drink so much
[__] soda it was still one kind or
just any kind of any sodas it's like
smoking weed like yeah I want to try
that [__] that's how bad it was okay
but I stopped when I moved to LA I'm
like I can't I'm gonna [__] this is
hurting hurting my stomach done
and I was like [__] give me my record
for your dream ever seen that movie
I'm aware of it okay you ever seen
record for a dream so the the scene
where they shoot up as soon as I hit
that soda
hit me again like uh same thing for
Homer when he eats the McRib [__] the
rib sandwich and it goes through his
blood that's what happened you're John
you're John Travolta driving home and
Pulp Fiction
that's me yep that's what I smelled that
[__] like
my body started [__] convulsing and
[__] I was driving anyway uh hooked
hooked I got hooked again uh my uncle
John was at two years ago I stopped
drinking soda officially a month and a
half ago no more that's all I don't even
look at it don't touch it don't get away
I was going so hard Marty and in the
past what year I'm like damn games away
oh [__] oh my stomach hurts I've been
going to the doctor because my stomach
what leaves that that soda is hurting my
stomach I started eating candy again so
that brings me the candy because I was
like I'm a drink startup I might as well
you can't even
it's vegan no hell no gelatin is a I saw
a video it was terrible so by definition
gel Tunes a byproduct of industrial meat
processing made from various animal
parts including bones Hooves skins
tendons ligaments and connective tissue
bro okay so when you're a vegetarian
you're out here living your life we're
talking about marshmallows which then
bleeds into Rice Krispie treats
candy corn Pop-Tarts Jello gummies
Frosted Mini weeks Hostess CupCakes pie
crust Altoids pop rocks and where they
really get you vegetable soup
French onion soup
the broth
oh were they really did you the gel the
gel caps on your supplements or your
medicine they still have to be vegan
fish oil pills you can't you're getting
bone you're getting hoof and ligament
all in there I don't think I don't even
understand what's going on there's a
video right and it shows a candy and it
just traces it right back to where it
starts
it's one of these videos that goes like
boom lighter and it goes back to truck
manufactured being put together uh melts
into plastic this one went backwards and
it just went backwards boom [__] uh
guts
dooky ass [__] me skin [__] pieces
of bone being processed into [__]
gelatin and into candy
I didn't know
it's all animal fat and Bones this
should be common knowledge that's [__]
up yeah Pop-Tarts come on terrible
anyway even if you're not vegan what the
[__] that's some future that'd be normal
yeah slime [__] yeah that's not fair
yo by the way these joints maybe we
should just have a joint this big all
the time I know like it is just usually
I burn through the joint the first
[__] five minutes yeah this thing is
like a pretty high a gentleman's cigar
yeah
perfect
yeah all right continue that was get the
[__] out of here
that's a great segment by the way I love
that you added that that's a good one
I'm gonna have I have a lot of them
yeah a lot of things falling in that
category oh yeah okay damn Marty
yeah what is this what's moving out we
got a little bit of Sports Talk
Sports Talk I've never seen Sports Talk
written in the [__] show I'm excited
it's not like we're next to some
athletes yeah yeah oh I made the joke
guys I am officially the shortest dude
on the shows but I'm the highest
[__] out of any of these fools
the irony
no I like it wait am I taller than my
Tyson no definitely shorter
yeah I don't be giving a [__] but yo
well I'm like maybe they got somebody
else by Kevin garnettling
God bro I'm gonna look like a little boy
alone
but now would you and the meet and greet
people like you're a lot taller than I
thought like oh you just you're not sure
I know you're just regular say that to
me well you know I don't know if you
guys know this my aunts six one six two
my uncle's six foot six foot my
grandma's brother six six six six six I
am the shortest dude
my brother is six two
I am the only one that didn't get hype
but I think I explain my dad for making
me lift weights when I was a child
remember he was I was [__] little
monster at four or five years old and
[__] yeah yeah little bastard
anyway
officially
the shortest and the highest building
it's okay sorry so let me ask you this
all right go when was the last time you
saw a Jon Jones fight
I stopped watching UFC when I was
really really starting to sell a lot of
packs because I didn't really care about
oh it's the fight I'm like I don't give
a [__] well I'm doing [__]
20 10. when I stopped actively watching
every [__] because remember I used to
get him at Blockbuster with my dad used
to rent UFC one you see two because we
used to play that and bet nickels and
dimes I was [__] six and that's how
we would bet and then my aunt was dating
Paul the polar bear [__] Matt he was
the UFC to my aunt that was her
boyfriend so I'm like that
[__] I was in the UFC man
Jon Jones I watched one fight and he
killed somebody with elbows and it was
so devastating I would never want to
fight you know sometimes you're like
damn I think I could
could [__] I know how to wrestle like it
just drain a little bit
how'd that be uh and then you see fools
like that come in with a ax kick and and
split someone's forehead with an elbow
I'm like bro get the [__] away from me
don't keep putting me in the ring with
that guy I don't want to fight him and
then I start thinking I better learn how
to fight because there's Fool's like
that outside walking around
six four uh 210 elbow oh my whole face
is
split I've been watching UFC since 2013
and oh so yeah I've only seen one Jon
Jones fight because of all of his
controversies he's been based on
controversies yeah but I don't keep up
oh what happened what do you do he's
just heavily been in controversial I
know he got Joe for some uh he had
various things various legal issues that
like amen kept him from not fighting
yeah he came back he fought this uh dude
over insane Peru he beat the [__] out of
him yeah and it was like all right but I
might have caught his like fights with
DC which were iconic
yeah but for the most part I really
haven't witnessed a lot of his career
he's been like sidelined since I've been
a fan if you as
I've seen almost all his fights
highlights yeah YouTube yeah but I've
never got it's like George I've caught
one fight solidly yeah knocking a fool
asleep in his elbows and he split him
down like to his uh oh
gross oh yeah Marvin Eastman's from
Merced beastman Eastman from USA that's
my homie's [__] Uncle so yeah UFC was
like a part of my [__] growing up
so we got UFC 284 coming up
first which is volcanovsky and a bunch
of people that I don't know but then
followed by that we got UFC 285 early
March Jon Jones first fight back who's
he fighting a dude another dude that I
don't know
Cyril gone cereal and I didn't know how
to pronounce his name
I put the enunciation on there
that's hard serial gain
he sounds like a villain serial gain
sounds like one of the most gangsters
Fitness yeah it sounds like some bigger
a guy that poses like that like a bane
that's what he looks like oh I can't
wait I need to start getting into [__]
now that you have three extra days a
week we should start doing stuff now now
I have a house I would have to [__]
squeeze my apartment not get smoking
complaints now we could do stuff all
right
um I'm excited this is officially the
first day yeah I got I moved in fully
today order some furniture orders
Furniture situated we're situated
you filmed a video in the garage and you
almost had to boot out other production
company ironically isn't that crazy guys
I moved into a place and uh right when I
started filming I'm like you know what
let's film in our own garage we have our
own garage holy [__] I have a garage I
was all hyped remember I sit down Nikita
presses play or record I go hey what's
up and I just hear people dying laughing
outside I'm like no [__] way
there's nobody lives next door to me
they're still building the house how is
this possible and I go outside it's a
[__] reality show being filmed I
don't know what reality show but there's
producers with little packs and Camera
dudes with some chicks with little dogs
boy are you [__] kidding me I'm
trying to HotBox this [__] get
out of here quietly yeah I'm trying to
look could you leave so I can feel
myself get high please that's how I feel
but it's also like that's your yard who
the [__] am I to say can you keep it
down if they told me like are you used
to they would tell you if a production
crew will tell you like you know but I
had to eat it after like he'd asked me
42 times like I'll just go out there and
ask him like no
no they're on their property who the
[__] am I keep it down you know yeah I'm
like dude who am I just say that but
also shut the [__] up a dog kept barking
and Nikita went out there came in he's
like they were nice oh okay because I
told you earlier in the day I saw people
outside I know they were filming but I
saw him I went oh hello and they all
just
I didn't care I was just being polite
you guys dissed the [__] out of me so I
didn't even want to talk to him again
because they were like no we're not keep
it down but I punched him in the [__]
head and I'd be in trouble we would have
missed today
you're good at avoiding these
confrontations I'm very good at it yeah
we talked about Rosie's [__] too yeah
yeah I don't know if we talked about on
here but yeah yeah we did we did yeah
look anyway sorry what happened UFC
so we got Jon Jones coming back uh I'm
excited to see it because I mean it's
really there's not been too much super
stardom going down in the UFC Nate Diaz
left
you know he's kind of like doing his own
thing now it's like McGregor's Been Gone
Forever you know there's Jon Jones is
really I mean you got Paul kanovsky he's
a superstar but not unlike Jon Jones
awareness level all right here
it's it's February we start watching UFC
again I bet I know I'm saying like
knowing who the [__] they are I should
know all these fools still my favorite
fighter I think might be Matt Hughes
okay that's not something yeah oh man
that fool [__] what's up or George Saint
Pierre yeah because he's also uh
Jean-Claude Van Damme of UFC I can
understand him
yeah but you have a slight like what did
he say oh [__] just kicks two dudes
that's Jean-Claude Van Damme except he's
not saving a lady and banging her in the
movie he's just your CM yeah God that
feels so
you ever see that clip of Rogan the
spinning back kick a little snap yeah
that's you know that feels kind of scary
yeah like oh you're podcasting funny guy
get through a wall
you're like why don't you uh snap like
that's why I like YouTube for stupid ass
useless information that I don't use for
a slip right now all right there we go
sorry Jon Jones Jon Jones and sports
news also on sports news
the controversy is over the conspiracies
are done tomorrow Hamlin's back alive
and well yeah in front of the camera no
[__] yeah yeah
I didn't see it yeah you gotta but you
saw it yeah there's four videos out
there now I think the rumors I don't
know I just saw so many videos I went
huh
yeah it was just I said I dropped my
phone whoa
I think it was just weird you know I
think it's just a weird situation and
like
like a shoe release but don't let him
see it make him think it's fake uh start
they've made they started those videos
I don't know who they are but you know
what I'm saying I'm just doing my uh
Alex Jones shirt it was them yeah
Spider-Man
sorry but at least that's some good news
for us to finish off the season you know
the fitness office
go on it you know it's just bent over uh
I mean he's back
yo I heard that Aaron Rodgers might be
leaving the Packers that's crazy you
were shocked when I brought to your
awareness how much he looks like not
only a 70s porn star but the dude from
40 year old version
Steve Steve Carell
Aaron Rodgers oh yeah he does look a lot
like Michael Scott I didn't notice they
have a sale a lot of similar features
man oh yeah it kind of [__] me up or
Aaron Rodgers looked a lot like uh
Nicholas Cage and Conair right now
very like he's got the look yeah scruffy
but like you're a good guy I can tell
you but he's still like in his prime
though yeah he's still a badass I just
hung up the [__] Jersey in my oh so
I'm so excited you gotta put a motion
detector on the little video part it'd
be sick
um
so damn all right we talked about sports
Marty whoa you wrote Sports into the
notes
all right so our goal now which I'll
talk to Marty my bro we're going into a
building where there's [__] legendary
athletes I'm over here out of shape and
go hey what's up so I'm like I gotta be
able to do a backflip for some pull-ups
or like you know because I can parkour
at basketball you've seen him like I
could and one dribble my ass off but I
might just like Miss the layup possibly
so it's like yo basketball nah these
guys are good oh what about like
fighting oh my ties is here okay what
about skating
um can I make you laugh can I do
something else I just think it's so
[__] funny it's so wild to me still
it's just hilarious like oh we're gonna
box this whole building so it feels good
[__] time yeah this is legendary so I
want to start it off like this thank you
guys a lot of good things but also
um I have a topic that I wanted to talk
about that's been pissing me the [__]
off I haven't talked about at all and uh
it's really bugging the [__] out of me
and I was right in the nose this morning
I'm like
no [__] that I'm gonna talk about it
because every time we talk about some
serious [__] people are always
commenting like yo that helped me right
now because I'm going through the exact
same [__] thing like I know you are
because you're alive when people
commented their favorite moments from
last episode a lot of that yeah yeah
a lot thank you guys for all taking the
time to comment on last week's comments
on YouTube your favorite moment from
season two I still got to pick I really
enjoyed looking through that and reading
everybody's responses it was dope dude
it was awesome like uh you could tell
our fans and we talked about it we're
Dela meet and greets and stuff
um
it was insane thank you for that turnout
I could not believe it before we start
let me try some of this we got some
funny ass people in [__] Dallas I've
been editing them
something like eight in the morning
and then I heard what he said like did
you incriminate yourself and then say
that you didn't incriminate yourself
two comes up to the cameras like
he was great too he was like one of the
best I'm not even gonna ruin it he's so
cool he was one of the best [__] that he
brought to sign oh yeah but he came up
to the camera like what did he say he's
like
down here in Dallas with the alligators
man got the got the right to bear arms
down here it's legal unless you see the
police here I mean because it's not
legal put us back
don't put that over here though maybe
he's like on parole We're not gonna put
that in the video okay yeah I don't want
him to say who it was but yeah when you
sent me that video BTS moment I know
like shut the [__] up and you know we
got it right here but you know what if
you see the police like bro stop
stalking don't talk to the camera like
that wrong with you what if I'm an idiot
I put that [__] in there yeah oh you can
tell you can smoke you should smoke
blunts by the way you smashed the joint
look how flat it is it must be I know I
can't hide this I know I see you like
pinching pinch pinch and try them all
right here we go
what's up guys it's taking a moment to
talk about one of our new sponsors and
this is mint mobile if one of your goals
for 2023 is to save more money that mint
mobile is perfect for you why are you
still paying insane amounts of money for
your phone stop getting taxed switching
to Mint mobile is the easiest way to
save this year as the first company to
sell premium wireless service online
only mint mobile lets you order from
home and save a ton with plans starting
at just 15 a month so once again if your
goal is to save more money start
spending less start with your phone bill
it is essential and every one of us gots
one some of these plans start at 15 a
month by going online only and passing
on the cost of traditional retail mint
mobile passes significant savings on to
you all plans come with unlimited talk
and text delivered on the nation's
fastest 5G Network use your own phone
with any mint Mobile plan and switch
easily in minutes with esim guys it
doesn't get any easier than that it
starts at 15 a month and it gets shipped
directly to your door for free just use
our code so go to mintmobile.com forward
slash Yola it's like 19.99 prices out
here guys take advantage of it right now
with mint mobile can't beat that go to
mintmobile.com Yola premium wireless
service delivered on the nation's
fastest 5G Network
so
[__] has been pissing me the [__]
off and like I said a lot of people talk
about things and if it helps I hope it
does and uh here we talk about a lot of
things and we read the comments we do
everything we talk about you guys in the
DMS we talk to you guys all that [__] so
this is what's going on
um
you guys know we've talked about you
always ask like yo your dad needs to
come on the show I'm like yo my dad's
offensive as [__] oh I want them to just
be editing out 90 of his [__] so this is
what's going on and like I said
this podcast this is our friends we're
all homies you guys know that if I met
you in person you already know that [__]
so
May 19th
right May 19th you guys know my dad used
to be a damn drug addict
and then he stopped doing drugs and he
started drinking I've seen my dad put a
straw on a fifth
and chugged the whole [__] thing it
was Jack Daniels after a move and I
watched him eat some lemon heads I'm
like bro what and then he's just
flopped my damn your [__] down
fifth so my dad used to be a monster
smoke crank all that you guys know these
things right my dad's been [__] drug
freeze a super sick ass dad to my
sisters my old brother it's insane
showing them to meetings and you were
talking about my dad a lot right so May
19th I believe for a really long time
right 15 years
right May 19th my dad's
birthday is the next day but the May
19th is the day we interviewed [__]
Tony Hawk and Jason Ellis
right yeah that's the day I was so
excited the biggest days of all time one
of the biggest days ever I was so high
before we started the podcast it goes I
was like yo one day we're gonna have
Tony Hawk on the show and then I'm gonna
challenge him in a game of Tony Hawk but
I'm gonna play as Tony Hawk playing Tony
Hawk in the game Tony Hawk and then I'm
gonna beat Tony Hawk using Tony Hawk you
know it was Inception remember that and
then the day came like yo we're gonna do
this [__] and then that morning my uh
my cousin texted me he's like yo what's
up with your dad I'm like what do you
mean what the [__] is up with my dad
he's awful's tripping I'm like what does
that mean fool what are you talking
about what do you mean he's tripping I
remember I hit you I'm like dude my
dad's tripping
and he's like yeah it was all [__] up
I'm like what do you mean he's [__] up
like he's drinking I'm like no he's not
supposed to drink a drop of alcohol is a
monster
and then then he's like telling me like
okay that's [__] [__] faced at my
dad's house right so I'm like oh Duke no
[__] all right so I try to get a hold of
my dad and we've talked about it before
but
I don't know about I didn't know that a
suppressed memory [__] was so real right
the second my cousin was talking about
it I remember I told you I'm like yo I
remembered like [__] 75 stories in my
head I forgot about I used to Chase my
dad down trying to find my [__] meth
houses and [__] I forgot we never even
talked about that [__] in stories I
forgot it erased my memory I don't know
what happened I forgot about it I used
to do that [__] all the time trying to
find his ass [__] face make sure he's
not driving like oh my God I completely
forgot about that part of my life I
don't know what happened it was eight
nine ten years yeah it was like a movie
and [__] like I forgot about it it's
like you know when you watch the old
episode like damn it's a good ass
episode that's how I feel but I was like
this one sucks dick I hate this [__]
episode of life and then so I call my
dad I'm like oh no the second and before
we start
I know a lot of people yeah you put your
dad on blast all this [__]
I don't give a [__] this one ain't
listening to me right now so maybe he
needs to be a little bit put on blast
[__] this I'm trying and I'll get on to
that and also I'm not trying to hurt his
feelings
and I hope the [__] that he he's gonna
be [__] up anyway right I'm trying to
help
but hopefully talking about it can help
somebody else out there because it's not
like he's helping anybody right now so
the day Tony Hawk comes that's two
[__] hours before we're supposed to
film
um like are you [__] kidding me and I
told you I went
and I just like forgot about my golf
deal with this [__] tonight and it's the
first time I actually like
and threw it out on some [__] I
couldn't believe I did that [__] and it
worked and then I and as we're
interviewing Tony Hawk I remember the
Smoke's gone and then I'm like
[__] my dad back your mind [__] I forgot
I think I forgot but I mean I told you a
point like that's the point I remember
you can see my face like
and I didn't want to show it because
remembering Tony like damn this [__]
guy's a dick you just give me a shitty
look you know what's Heath he doesn't
know what's going on so afterward I'm
talking to my I call my dad a second I
talk I'm like oh my God here we [__]
go like I can hear your voice the second
you talk I'm like [__] he called you you
said I called him like no dude this is
it I'm like are you [__] tweaking
like because I heard something in his
voice to go are you [__] on one
because now I'm bigger I'm like I'll
[__] beat this [__] I'm not gonna
beat him up he's on drugs but I'm like
as a kid I couldn't really
full force tell him how I felt because
he might [__] me up I don't know he's
strong as [__]
um
but yeah I hear him like are you
tweaking fool and my cousin my uncle
texted me he's like your dad's got his
gun and [__] so I ain't trying to go to
his truck every time my dad used to get
[__] up he'd Park his diesel in my
grandma's property and just chill in his
truck for like a week dude tweaking
don't go up to his ass he's a monster
when he's [__] up I hate that fool
when he's [__] up
I hope he watches this [__] I [__]
hate this phone he's [__] up
and uh I'm on the phone with him I'm
like uh and I keep doing the same [__] I
do with my homies when they're [__] up
like no you're fine of course of course
you're allowed to get [__] it's fine
he's like see man I knew you understand
I'm just trying to be his homie and I'm
like
he's like dude I've been smoking and
[__] I've been chilling like what did
you say he goes no I'm not just been
drinking I'm like [__]
Harry I knew I [__] heard it in his
voice
oh [__] like makes me feel like [__]
ugh
and then and then like
I'm talking to him
and I hear someone else I'm not going to
say everything but I recognize the
person's voice and that's when I all the
[__] [__] came back and I just
started thinking about all the times I'm
not gonna say this person's name or who
they are but thinking about how much I
hated that [__] person he chilled
with because I remember there'd be times
like I told you like for soccer games
like yo you said you were showing up
well and you never show up and then I'd
go buy a certain person's house I'm like
oh
[__] tweak it [__] like damn fool
show up sometimes you know but I'm like
dude I'm in my 30s now I heard that
fool's voice and I'm like dude that [__]
brought me back to like a little kid I
like wanted to like just hear like
because I forgot you know I was saying
like I remember the situation I forgot
how many times I had to deal with his
people and how many times I've scolded
full adults as like a 10 year old like
what the [__] like you know me like I
talk the same as I did as a kid my dad
always says that you're exactly the
[__] same for when you were two years
old talking [__] like I'm not talking
[__] I'm just telling you you're stupid
as [__] out of my car yeah I remember
I was like six he's like get in the car
my dad you're drawing you're drunk as
[__] I'm not getting your truck then my
uncle's like damn you're look at him
he's [__] smart you're right stay
here and then they started doing [__]
Donuts [__] facing took off and I was
like six like
these kids like I was the adult always
hiding his [__] because I knew the cops
were coming so I'd like high pipes and
how was that kid like just stashing [__]
and I forgot I didn't even talk about
this [__] in story times because I
forgot I forgot I used to do this [__]
so I heard them this bitch's voice and
I'm like oh my God you [__] [__] I
hate this fool so much and then I
remembered oh [__] you're hot and I
remember what his [__] house looks
like and all the times I'd be like yo
fool can you [__] come outside you've
been gone for a week type [__] right and
uh
it all hit me right after the Tony Hawk
[__] I called him and then right after
Tony Hawking I drove to Merced even
though we had so much [__] to do oh my
[__] I gotta drive him Merced because I
can't find him because my cousin was
trying to Circle town because once my
dad's gone he's gone bro he's
it's scary because he won't he he never
has once not lost the phone so you can't
get a hold of this [__] tweaker for
forever I don't mean like talking to my
dad because he's dope as [__] if he can
just get clean like my dad's right back
to being a badass again yeah and I know
I should probably there's a lot of
you're talking about tweaker mode
version of him tweaker mode version my
dad's a [__] [__] and uh
yeah it's been going on for like seven
eight months now I've been dealing with
this [__] again
and the thing is my little sisters and
brothers are alive now he hasn't been
tweaking around them and ever they've
never seen it so my little sister hit me
up and that's how I originally found out
like it's bad like he pulled some [__]
on them at the fair and they were
calling me like embarrassed and like I
was walking them through the steps how
to get his ass to the car like so what
you gotta do is tell them this like yo
we're gonna go to the house you can just
you know drink there no one wants a beat
I was trying to like walk them through
like so this is how you walk this
[__] through this this is how
you get him excuse me to the car
make sure he stays make sure he does
this make sure you [__] put these
Keys away don't let this [__] disc be
out because you know it's good like I
know all the steps and she's like oh it
is there I'm like [__] man
damn this voice has not changed I mean
he has but like
I know a lot of people at home are like
[__] dude I'm going through that [__]
too I know I just haven't talked about
it because I don't want to put him on
blast but
there's a point and I'll get to that
point but there's a point of like
come on dude
and I've never got to talk tell him that
because I was always so scared as a kid
to tell him how I really felt you know
what I'm saying because he I don't know
what he's gonna do and I could not take
his ass one-on-one back then I could
dip him to the ground hella times but
eventually he's just gonna my dad bites
a bit of Fool's face off bro I'm I'm
good I'm trying to Marvin Gaye [__]
happen when my my dad was [__] up and
shot his ass I know a real [__] fear
of mine like I ain't gonna have that
happen to me like destroy yourself well
I'll stand on the other side over there
you've done this battle with so many
people oh my [__] God but that's why
I done it with so many of my homies
because I know how to do it
but I was always so [__] broke my dad
my dad's dad was a piece of [__]
and my dad's been work since you're 13
Had Me At You Know 17 18 he's been
working had more kids now they're 18. I
was trying to tell him like on the phone
like well you've never had a chance you
never like went to rehab you'd have
toughed it out you've just been like all
right I just want the drugs anymore like
probably that's not something's bugging
you you gotta go to [__] rehab and
now Mike bro I found a place it's bougie
[__] I think it's a therapy this the
[__] spot I told you oh my God I
don't have that money but I'll [__]
I'll do it but that's when I was broke
is like things are doing a lot better I
know it's only a couple months later but
like it's it's working better and
I told him I've walked at you in rehab
I'll get you a house he's like I hate
driving I hate driving it slowly I'm
lonely as [__] on the road because when
he's drunk he tells me everything he
tells me everything you wanted to start
his Pizza Company yeah I'm like all
right let's go back and it's part of
pizza so I talked about on the show but
I was like yeah I start a pizza spot so
hopefully like somebody sees it and
asked him about it but I didn't say why
I was saying to save his [__] ass
because I'm like dude you got to stop
driving then I'll get you a house let's
go get a house like no Tom's like Dad
you don't realize what I'm doing right
now I can go get you a house right now
you can retire don't ever work again
open the pizza spot you never have to
drive a truck again do the pizza spot
because you know you're not gonna just
sit around you have to be moving you're
always going to be moving I you know I
mean I put it all like this come on
please yeah I yeah gift wrap please
please man like every problem you have
you I can stop it right now I haven't
tell my dad
my dad with the kind of things I'm doing
he has no idea what I'm doing I already
asked me he's like you I was like I
don't make that money a year I'm like
oh yeah that's crazy like no like and
he's like damn that's a lot of money I'm
like oh hell yeah he's like I'm almost
there I'm like oh sick dad and I was
just talking about three weeks and I'm
like damn dad you have no idea how much
we're crushing it I didn't want to feel
like yeah you know how much money I'd
even say a [__] word I went yeah that
is damn that's a lot of that's a lot but
my damn dad's my monthly income full I'm
trying to get [__] popping over here
yeah you got to talk to people on a
level yeah I don't want to make him feel
like oh Jesus Christ so I'm like damn
that's not but by offering all that [__]
but I'm trying to like ease it in like
come on we'll get it because he's
[__] tripping
anyway that was that whole conversation
like dude we'll start a pizza spot and
he's like [__] yeah let's do it I'll
[__] face but I'm like let's get him in
that motive like all right I ain't gonna
get uh maybe I'll just go home we'll
start it up like I'm trying to get it I
don't know
but it's been going on dude my sister's
calling me I'm trying to do this I have
my cousins like follow him to make sure
he's just chilling because he'll [__]
run off
and he never lets my grandma grandpa
know he's [__] up and yeah he's
beginning
my dad [__] ruined Christmas man
my dad never should face in front of my
grandma grandpa because they're so
anti-fucked up anti-drugs and [__] and
my dad was so [__] [__] face that
Christmas
my grandpa didn't even come out of the
room because he was so pissed off my
grandpa's
my grandpa's not probably gonna make it
to this next Christmas he's [__] up
and I just kept thinking
last Christmas and you ain't coming out
like Dad you are [__] up did he know
that
your dad was he aware of what like what
uh I could tell he was smoking too
because the way he was talking like [__]
he didn't notice your grandpa wasn't
hanging out oh hell no dude and
everybody's just like
doing this like what's he gonna do
what's he gonna do what's he gonna do we
have like 30 people out over and every
one of them feels uncomfortable because
like my dad's a life of the party he's
funny as [__] he jokes with everybody
he's like the guy like all right get
that bro let's go and here he is just
[__] up looking like [__] by the
fireplace
and it's just it [__] everybody realizes
I could feel that [__] but before it
happened I pulled up and Rosie's never
seen my Dad drunk so I'm like Rosie
don't say nothing to my dad walk him I
was like I do not want him talking to
you [__] up because if he says
anything wrong I'm gonna
I'm gonna whoop the [__] out of it you
know like I don't care you're my dad I'm
Gonna Knock you asleep if you say but
he's probably gonna say something my
dad's a [__] offensive ass fool so he
says some [__] and if you shift hey you
already know you know what I'm saying
I'm like I don't want to even be put in
that position so I was like let's just
go straight in the house I'm gonna talk
to my dad as soon as I walked up he's
like y'all I'm sorry I'm like bro and I
know I didn't talk to you about this but
[__] that [__] I'm gonna talk about it
and I finally got to talk to him like an
adult because he's never been shit-faced
like ever all this [__] that I've
remembered after because I've been doing
this for eight months every other day
I'm getting a call talking my grandma
talking to my dad trying to [__] calm
him down directly before the Ted Talk
bro why didn't even show up to Ted Talk
[__] [__] didn't even show up
that made me feel like a little kid
again yeah like before you said you were
gonna come
all right it's okay but I was trying to
like [__] it who cares I'm an adult now
like I don't care but it bugged me like
you're still a human you said you it's
the most important thing we've ever done
all right bro I gotta live my life all
right you're a shitty friend that's how
I feel like you're such a bad friend
right now and he didn't even show up man
I don't even talk about it I know a lot
of fans like what's your dad I'm like oh
he'll be you know I felt like that again
like oh no
I'm speaking right now and he can't he's
not showing up
I this is a week month ago and I'm like
yeah you'll be here I was in that mode
again like where's your dad like he's
working I was that was my loud like he's
tweet
he's not gonna come like but he didn't
even show up in Ted Talk I was so like
did he remember to like did he give you
an excuse or something he called me two
hours before like oh yeah hey
you're [__] up all right for sure
didn't even bring it up
just I knew he wanted to and he wanted
me to bring it up
I was like oh for sure all right man
I'll talk to you later hung up and
started to kept steady I was like
nah bro I can't be thinking about your
ass right now but afterward my cute
[__]
I should think about my mom and how bad
a relationship I'm like she's here she's
always here so many people were there
she's but like how much I used to not
like my mom when we were yeah you know
what I mean like dude no matter what she
was always [__] there my dad not so
[__] much ever he's been there for a
tenth of my life and it's like dude
it's okay but he's such a dope ass fool
that I'm like come on you're hilarious
so anyway yeah he didn't [__] show
the Ted Talk that piece of [__] [__]
man and I'm not saying please don't like
be a dick if you know my dad and he's
not my he's my dad but he's in a
different brain right now all right are
you allowed to feel that way yeah but
like four days out of the week he's
completely sober working
that's my dad he gets [__] face goes on
a bender for three days
hey what's up man no no go just fixing
the house back to normal so that's why
it's hard to talk to him about [__]
because he's always avoiding it always
avoiding it is he really defensive about
it
my dad's so emotional and [__] he
doesn't want to start talking about it
so it's so hard to get it out of it
every time after he's sober I'm gonna
talk to him he makes sure to stay around
everybody so I can't bring it up I know
he he thinks he's slick but I know those
tactics you've been doing in my whole
life yeah like well don't you all right
yeah you're gonna go to the living room
okay where everybody's at for sure I
can't even get a word in all right for
sure sick sick all right let's go to the
store oh let's go to the movies with
everybody yeah you can't talk in the
movies all right you're [__] [__]
[__] like he knows what he's doing
but I got there at Christmas
guys like Rosie go inside
and I talked to my dad and this fool was
So Gone
I just talked to him for but I remember
there was a point
where like he took something wrong I
said I was like whoa I show up like I
live in L.A and [__] I still show up and
he looked at me like so gives a [__] you
live in L.A
he's kind of said it like bro I live in
L.A and I I don't know why it bugged me
so much I almost punched him in the
[__] head
but I looked at him like because my dad
has a surgery he has the [__] bypass
the lap band [__] and he's over here
drinking he's not supposed to be [__]
drinking and doing all this stuff he has
horrible ass team he's been going to the
[__] he has [__] popping out of his
teeth we're going to Mexico yeah [__]
done species remember during season two
I'm like my dad's been at my house we're
watching football and [__] this is great
remember yeah we talked about like [__]
was going good
I've never been able to hang out with my
dad in my [__] life
and it's like dude you're [__] up so
bad it's it doesn't make sense to me
and I was just telling like Bro Look at
Johnny like don't do that [__] to him
like he likes you
like he still keep him like thinking
you're the [__] and doesn't matter and I
remember he said this [__] to me when I
was 19 I was like bro you act like
getting [__] up is more important than
me and all the kids it's like of course
it is and he looked at me he's like I
don't care about you guys I just want to
get [__] up oh [__] I was like all
right Dad there it is he said that [__]
to me I'm like
[__] you're done you're gone he said
when I was 19. I remember I was so
I was so [__] mad
and he said this [__] to me again the
other day on Christmas I'm like
all right Dad sick because this time
like I don't care now I mean I'm mad and
like pissed about it but now I'm more of
like
bro
I have the coolest [__] life
everything is gone
out of the situation because I'm like
you just said that [__] to me again
because it sounds like it's like there
was your dad and then there was like
your dad on and and his addiction but
now there's like a blurred line between
like oh yeah he's doing a very good job
of it now he's going off three days a
week I'm completely but if he's saying
[__] like that like that I know when
he's fully [__] up
and when he said it I was like you
[__] you didn't just say yeah it
is you went hard it was like about the
meanest thing you could say to okay so I
don't give a [__] about you I just want
to get [__] up oh come on you piece of
[__] oh you're such an [__] have any
of your friends ever said anything like
that in that state when you're trying to
help them out
do they all say horrible [__] or is that
no no no no no no no because they know
me
and they know I'm really really trying
to help
they know what's up they know what's up
except saying when saying blew me the
[__] off that time which was crazy so he
did do that [__] to me but I could tell
for the way he was looking at him oh
you're [__] on one like oh I was
gonna leave you alone bro you're not
here right now my dad I'm like you're
just drunk
you're such a [__] [__]
and I just you know
it got to a point where he like stepped
up to me and I'm like the little kid in
my head I was like
away punch you with the [__] head and
I was like nah bro I'll hurt him but I
remember I don't know what came over me
but I got like nine inches taller and I
punked the [__] out of this man on
Christmas Day I have never felt more
Giant in my I was like damn I just Punk
no we're outside for two and a half
hours everybody's in the living room
doing Christmas
me and my dad were outside for two
[__] hours talking and my grandma
kept peeking after she told me like I
just didn't want you to hear them
because she knows like I'm not a little
kid anymore for oh [__] you up now
because you used to say [__] [__] [__]
anyway
I like stepped up to him and then he
went
back down with no way oh damn I'm not
gonna hit you I'll [__] kill you now
like you're too old you're little uh
it's not gonna happen he goes
I'm like whoa you didn't say [__] you're
a little [__] now I'm not saying that
but in my head I was a damn fool for
real
you agree with me
hey the little kid in me was like yo I
ate a mushroom Mario bro yeah but in
real life I was like oh that made me
feel terrible
I know like I don't want to say that too
you're we were just hanging out three
weeks ago at my house watching [__]
highlights what the hell is going on you
know because he'll come to my house
completely sober he'll bring my little
sisters so I can't talk to him yeah like
he's he knows what he's doing so we
can't never bring it up because he just
wants to like you don't live here
anymore I'm not having conversation with
you I'm [__] up over here so anyway
that's what's going on my dad
I don't know man I've offered everything
I could possibly offer him
every [__] rehab thing every single
thing he don't give a [__]
so it's a phase right now and he goes to
these binges so maybe
I don't know man I don't know what to do
so you feel like maybe it's time to just
kind of back up a little bit and for the
first time ever I'm gonna go like that
you got it
you handle your [__] bro because if you
don't give a [__] how can I keep trying
I'm doing this for eight months every
[__] day I've been telling my dad's
tripping and there was like four months
ago I'm like yo my dad's chilling I had
a conversation with him where he was
like all right why don't we [__] up
friends to mention that I know I'm
[__] up
I gotta stop and I had a real
conversation for like an hour
and then two weeks later it was Chris
I'm like bro what the [__] dude and I
text my little sisters she's about to go
to college
she's the one that holds his ass
together and it's like
what's gonna happen
I don't know what's gonna happen so
that's where we're at right now I know
it's a bummer but
that's what the [__] I've been dealing
with it every single day it's such a
hassle dude I know it's people like
might sound selfish I'm just saying I've
been doing this since I was born
you know until I was like 19 and then
I'm from my 20s like damn my dad is sick
now because when we met you like no my
dad's tight he's funny as [__] City
he still is dope as hell
no
I don't want him around me at all
when he's [__] up even a nah
nah sorry I know I keep saying it but
yeah that's what's going on I just want
to talk about that [__] because I know a
lot of fools are going through that too
and a lot of people dude at the Houston
Houston meet and greet yeah I checked my
phone for the first time boom it's gonna
text from my uh Uncle Mike your dad I
just read the whole my oh oh
and I remember the girls like you good
yeah my dad's just [__] up
what's up and I just went back to like I
can't let this [__] there's literally
1300 people in front of me like I can't
I was just checking the time yeah like
how have we been
[__] [__] and that was it the
Ted's I remember I was like I managed my
stress yeah I learned how to do it so
this whole year is about
[__] Dragon Ball Z that [__] [__]
out of me like no no thanks dude I don't
even want that negativity around me
sorry so much for turning this into a
[__] bummer now it's important
highlight though you can't just sit here
and talk about all the good stuff
exactly
it's like there's always a contrast to
that we might not know about it's such a
[__] hassle
that sad
but it's so annoying
but it's different being an adult going
through it now though yeah of course way
different man because you have your own
life and I have other fools to take care
of that or want that are trying yeah
it's like damn fool I have to take care
of every because I have two little
sisters and a brother that still live
with him it's like so I gotta take care
of them too
[__] [__] all right here we go
how long is this one gonna be like I
hope this one's you're just like on a
vacation right now I hope it's like yo I
just did it here back my dad I told my
dad what if I get you a spot and every
Sunday we don't bug you you do whatever
the [__] you want on Sunday get [__]
face get [__] faced till Monday
but come Monday morning Monday night how
about you just come back and chill like
take care of your [__] family
[__] that [__]
so I was like oh oh dude I could hand it
to you on a platter my dad retire
I'll pay for everything you [__] do
don't worry about it nothing
crazy so I know I'm like how strong that
I got to step up a little bit yeah as we
step off a little bit then because I
already know where you're at I know this
I know this guy you've gone to the max
of what you can offer yeah there's
nothing more I could do except like no
no there's nothing more I can do
literally literally I've drove I haven't
talked about this I've drove to Merced
like 15 [__] times in the middle of
the night this year this past year
because [__] was going on I know he has
he's
yeah a bunch of stuff a bunch of stuff
going on but not everything is a win all
right yeah with the [__] new house
and all that sick [__] you know with the
new studio and stuff but we still got to
talk about things that are real and
things that happen and things that
matter and I hope they help somebody out
there because I know
75 of you just are looking at yourself
like damn my mom is tweaking right now
hard I just saw that [__] on the corn
she won't even [__] come home and she
I get it for and I know it's so weird to
say it because I forgot I know he keeps
saying it but damn I really did forget
about that part of my life dude I really
did forget about
all the shitty people that I saw
and I forgot I just Punk a [__] out of
one of them and the [__] was just
laying in a field by my grandma's like
hey [__]
the [__] are you doing here nothing just
waiting for waiting for Helmer to go
that's my and I scolded this woman for
so long say I don't even do drugs go I
tell you what happened
hold on before we end the show I gotta
[__] here we go here we go here we go
this hoe my mom has beat up multiple
times in high school because she's the
[__] that always chilled with my dad
when they were tweaking okay stupid
[__]
she keeps trying to come around my
grandma's
right because they lived in the country
too so there's a field by my grandmas
yeah you know like if you don't if you
know me personally you know my grandma
is that you know the fields
I went over there on Thanksgiving and I
go is that a tweaker in the bush
stop go hey
what's going on out here and someone's
all she's asking for someone to go who
is this [__] asking and I saw her go oh
that's that [__] from when I was a kid
the girl I used to I hated this lady
I I know if she's around my dad's not
around yeah if she's even in sight my
dad's gone
tweet he's gone
and it was Thanksgiving Day my dad was
sober as [__] and I looked at my dad
like yo I didn't say her name but so and
so he goes
tell her right here I go you
[__]
like I know that [__] look you just
went [__]
[__] [__] all right I ain't trying to
tweak yet but maybe I will tomorrow I
can see on his face like you bastard you
it's Thanksgiving fool are you plucking
serious you're plotting
and then anyway so hold on go back to
the good part and then I walked down
there because I'm an adult now I'm like
[__] I could
I'm not gonna hold you yeah I'm Gonna
Get You and I was just hitting her with
levels of like why are you here my
grandma doesn't like she's like that's
my grandma mom like you know who I am
I'm Elmer's son she was like oh my yeah
you know my mom and she just stopped and
go yeah we don't you shouldn't be here
we're all trying to have a family thing
every one of these people works for a
living and don't smoke meth so could you
please get away from us it's
Thanksgiving I can be here however I
want she's on the other side of the
fence so it's just public land so she
can't she's tweaking that's our tit like
you're sleeping in the field and then I
go hey stop tweaking around us you damn
tweaker stop we don't smoke meth and she
goes I don't do drugs I don't do drugs
and you ready for this Marty and I went
you have no shoes on it's Thanksgiving
you're laying in a field drinking Pepsi
you're gonna tell me you don't smoke
meth and she went
and she looked she left I laughed up the
driveway because I'm like yo nobody was
here for this one
[__] I might as well if it was 2004 to
pop my [__] collar up and walked away
I felt so hello
she had no shoes on laying laying in a
field
trying to hide from the cars coming by
so she could try to sneak into our
property and try to talk to my dad
okay I get it now bro I felt so amazing
the look on her face and she went damn
you really did just describe
yeah I am drinking Pepsi all right damn
I do got no shoes on I am Thanksgiving
that's what she said she was [__] I am a
tweaker and she just left so
um yeah that was my win for Thanksgiving
I will just stop with the Tweeter talk
and that was it and yeah it was good all
right yeah it was good [__] let's do it
[__] oh did she leave she left
immediately okay she couldn't say
anything she was so articulate for a
tweaker I was shocked when she was
rebuttaling
damn [__] oh yeah that's my grandma are
you doing you're one of the mathematics
Tweakers no she was on some [__] and
then I hit her with that she left so
yeah I felt like I was in the schoolyard
and everybody went oh and I looked
around like nobody's here for this I'll
talk about here we are one day what day
and that day is months later so I'm
sorry for the tweaker talk and all the
sad things but we had to happen and I'm
guessing
136 what are we filming that Creature
Talk sounds like a new segment
I was gonna say 132
three four times I've hit it directly oh
yeah oh yeah all right here we go
I don't know what else that was it damn
that was a long rant my bad guys my bad
it's a long time it's season three
episode one episode one [__] and we
started off with highlights and dope
[__] and edited with problems and not
fun stuff just because this podcast is
not about all the cool things it's
always about everything that's going on
Mario [__] we don't want to deal with
Marty big time other stuff I don't want
to be [__] dealing with constantly oh
but we're here all right for every win
there's a [__] bummer but if you can
take the bummers with the wins I think
that's life and you're winning all right
and I think that's the point of the
whole show and I just realized we do not
have headphones on yeah I just realized
that right now yeah I thought it was
going to be a little bit weirder but I
just [__] realized that guys
remember I said that before I started I
go down what's wrong oh yeah the hat I
don't have headphones I just looked I
saw you with headphones with it
I've never had headphones on that's
what's different
this feels great I just wanted to come
into a solo episode to open it up we got
a bunch of good guests book we're really
excited to get in here
bunch of [__] sorry for everybody on the
road just like damn that [__] just got
suppressing hey man sometimes life drugs
problems accomplishments you know what
you sign up for everything in between
like Jon Jones fights yeah here we go
guys uh Marty do you have anything else
you want to say we can close this out
for the first time in the new set and
shout out to everybody that made this
set look at this look at this let's just
talk about it for just a second episode
one through four we had backlighting and
we both loved it loved it and now it's
back so thank you guys it looks really
good in here like I'm super stoked on
how this looks I know the fans are going
nuts in the chat right now and yes it's
the same exact artist Zay Zoe how do you
say his name
z-a-o-n-e yeah the one right yeah dope
as hell thank you so much for coming out
here again David for knocking this out
thank you so much guys uh this is season
three episode one do us a favor drop a
like notification about all that stuff
we are fully not just me and Marty
anymore we have a team we're gonna go
above all right we're really excited
everyone here is so super stoked I'm
ready to go I'm ready to
I'm ready to get started man 2023 is
exciting [__] all right we're just
putting it out there in the atmosphere
Eddie Murphy is going to be sitting at
the table one day all right I've been
talking to Marty about it I'm calling it
is every season's gonna call it all
right because we do call it every season
yeah and we've what four we're on track
yeah on track all right I want Eddie
Murphy to be sitting right there I'm
gonna be talking some [__] I'm calling
Brian Cranston
I'm only gonna talk about his Seinfeld
character
only like yo what have you been doing
since yeah
what you've been doing this Malcolm in
the Middle you should get in a dream
real quick your honor I don't know if
you watch that if you haven't is it dope
it is the beard had me thinking oh what
is this gonna be man I haven't even
gotten to the part where he has the
beard but I've been watching it's a nice
little it's not breaking bad but it's up
there Brian Cranston the beard is like
you know it's gonna be kind of scary
like Robin Williams can be sad
okay yeah that makes sense yeah no he he
told the line of evolving from good guy
to evil guy in this similar to Breaking
Bad but I I love it it's a nice little I
needed that I needed a new shell and go
check it out
I have been watching [__] I've been
watching Seinfeld and smoking joints in
my bed yeah well now that the bills are
done me and April needs something to
watch now the bills are done dude Marty
doesn't watch football unless it's the
bill so he's not gonna watch the Super
Bowl even though your commercials that
you filmed are going to be in it I
watched the Super Bowl and I Snapchat
like are you filming that Marty
I already have like years and years
three years yeah so this Super Bowl oh
wait this Sunday yeah
yeah this Sunday and remember if you're
gonna bet go to DraftKings all right
all right I don't remember
it's gonna be awesome I'm so [__]
high yeah I think it was the hash too
but I'm pretty you got five tips on the
tip yeah
I said all right all right I'm sorry
Marty anything else you want to say no
thank you guys appreciate all the love
and support on Instagram and on YouTube
really made this week a lot easier and I
love hearing everybody's stories and
everybody's so nice and the support
makes hard things better so thank you
guys I'm Gonna Keep crushing it in
season three
and guys thank you so much for every
single thing that like I say just press
and like just being here just being
positive toward us is support you don't
have to buy a damn shirt but if you do
it that'd be sick you don't have to buy
[__] to support you being here everybody
at the meet and greets just telling us
like yo I get put my earbuds in I work
at Amazon just doing chicas I'm cracking
up fools like I'm crazy and I know you
guys are doing that right now you just
looked around and people are looking at
you I like to do that [__] because you
know what's happening right now that
just happened so yes dude thank you guys
for every single person out there if
you're in school if you're at work if
you are riding in a bus if you're doing
anything you're a jogging and you're
listening to us and you're being
positive we appreciate you thank you for
supporting us this is season three
episode one thank you guys I don't know
how many times I'm gonna say it but
thank you we're here it's officially
real we appreciate you guys before you
leave all right we gotta start doing
that leave a like on the video whether
it's Spotify Apple music but most
important YouTube leave a like on that
[__] press share send it to a homie if
you thought it was awesome that would
help a lot thank you guys so much and uh
I think that's it that's cool thank you
guys all right guys this has been the
dope as usual podcast this is Marty
O'Neill I'm dopa Zola have a dope ass
day
whoa this is usually when I would go
I'm so [__] high
it's I don't know what it is but I I
feel extra high today was that I mean
yeah but Giant Cannon of a Suge Knight
joint I don't know I just I think it's
the hatch I really gotta stop smoking
yeah
[Laughter]
thanks for watching the podcast if you
thought this was dope you'll like this
episode too and don't forget the best
way to support the show telehoney